night now and after this pawn push he's  trying to win this black rook with his  own pawn and uh this is even more  sadistic than the other idea that we  showed uh eric has to block the pawn  advance but magnus now can win at will  this pin is never disappearing he will  win the blackrook at his leisure what a  move  that was by by magnus as well i mean uh  he's calculated that yeah he's just  three seconds two seconds one second  eric has to make the move did he make a  move has he moved in time eric it's  tight  he's lost on time it looks like oh no  worse kind of ending to the day for eric  hanson another win for magnus carlsen he  decides the match three points four  magnus carlsen  that means he's in lead in the oslo  esports cup a loss for eric hanson who  just runs off what happened in the end  there  i mean the position is bad it's almost  hopeless anyway but eric just couldn't  find a logical move so he let his clock  run down